[Music]
in Fitbit don't lie news oh look at that
yeah she loves them oh I do like it but
I do think it lies why because something
we'll all three okay so sometimes like
it alerts you attend minutes before the
hour every hour to go take out 250 steps
but sometimes it does it like while I'm
brushing my teeth or whatever and it
will be like Nina go to 200 steps and
then it'll say by the end of me brushing
my teeth that I took 250 steps nah I
didn't they're rare and brushing my
teeth a long time so she did all because
it thinks you're fine but you ain't
going I feel like my boys like to recess
I could just be doing like this all day
and then it'll be like you ran like five
miles and I'll be like wow I've gonna
lose a lot of weight but then I don't
you got to put on your ankle submitted
by I wish to you and very happy healthy
baby oh happy how they baby a baby a
baby this has been how to use a murdered
woman's Fitbit to charge her husband
what whoa you got everything right with
it it doesn't work what I said I didn't
think of a Fitbit oh well I mean I
definitely wouldn't think of that either
does the Fitbit GPS you yeah it does
yeah dude I would just uh if I'm
representing myself which I would do in
Marcus ah I think if I was the accused
and I'm representing myself which I
would do oh cool I think no I would I
would oppose the Bisset like if somebody
from Fitbit and I'd be like like a key
okay so you won't you were to tell me
this [ __ ] hundred percent works because
what about when she used to jerk me off
and it said like she went for many miles
and the guy would be like booking oh no
no it's not Connor percent accurate come
on it's not it can't be you know what I
didn't walk to a pretty successful as
where should my teeth that was really
that's
yes all right so this stories about
Richard and Connie
Richard is 40 years old Connie was 39 Oh
what oh yeah killed her this all takes
place in Canal Connecticut so back on
December 23rd 2015
Richard claims so I'm going to tell you
his timeline first
that's almost Christmas like so his side
of the story is it on Christmas or is it
the night before Christmas
22news is too deeply 2040s so his story
is that sometimes before 8:30 a.m. he
took his two thumbs to the bus stop and
he returned home for his work shirt at
8:30 he left for work while connie was
still at home getting ready for her
class at the YMCA between 8:45 and 9:00
a.m. he returned home because he forgot
his laptop he also got a text alert that
their health alarm had been activated
Richard heard a noise and went upstairs
to investigate he claimed that he saw an
intruder which was a masked man about 6
feet 2 inches it stocky build wearing
camouflage masks and gloves
the intruder manhandled him and began
torturing him with a blowtorch while
being strapped to a chair
he claimed the intruder stabbed him with
it with the box cutter as well they
started a fight when he heard his wife
returned home and yelled for her to run
the intruder walked downstairs and
followed Connie to the basement
quite an ovation she ran the basement to
make sense I know
good night door that is exactly if he's
playing around you know where she went
stories have so many holes Richard I
attempted to go after them but handed up
tripping downstairs he claimed that he
heard a gunshot such a few go and but he
couldn't hear Connie for about five
minutes
that's when the intruder pointed the gun
gun
him and that's when he wrestled with the
suspect anyone he burned the intruders
face with the torch and the intruder
dropped the torch put his hand to his
face and ran out so he says wash new
roll about ten eleven he crawled back up
the stairs with the chair still attached
to his wrists he sent some panic button
on his alarm in the also call 9-1-1
that's his story and then I bet you
anything he stood there with the chair
stolen test was risked so that he could
look like he got captured when the cops
came because he thinks that's pretty
dope I bet you anything hey hey you guys
see this yeah I didn't bother to take it
off I did yeah I just wanted to know I
couldn't get out of it pretty good not
just good I didn't I just want to make
sure you guys see this yeah yeah so
police they were scouring the entire
area of the couldn't find a suspect the
canines were brought in to locate
someone running from the property was
the only thing that they picked up on
tracks directly to Richard which is like
[ __ ] dog the investigators also found
no evidence of a forced entry and
nothing in the house was taken and also
so then the cops were able to obtain
search warrants for Connie's Fitbit both
cellphones computers and the house alarm
log so this is what the evidence
high-minded at 9:01 Richard's log on to
his computer at home at 904 he sent his
supervisor an email saying an alarm had
gone off at his house and that he needed
to go back and check on it
at 9:23 Connie's Fitbit registered
movement at 9:40 through 946 she was
active on Facebook posting videos on her
page with her iPhone and the IP address
was the same as a home between 9 18 to
10:05 she was at home her Fitbit
recorded a distance of 1207
thief could be jacking off very possible
without the V c'mon
yeah but they're saying so the cops are
saying so we were using this against him
because they said that it would take
Hani to walk from her car to the
basement or it was that she died no more
than 125 feet it was very clear that she
was involved in some sort of struggle or
partially because it was like a thousand
times
yeah a thousand two hundred seventy P I
couldn't not oh yeah no that's where you
want yeah and so another thing that
worked against him is the fact that he
attempted to make a claim for his wife's
life insurance insurance policy agree
more four hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars five days after she
died I think she did die yeah but I
guess I've just read more about hold man
I don't think that would be the first
thing on my mind life insurance is one
of those things that's like later oh
yeah I have that thing because the first
four days alike where you had to go up
and I but maybe I would be but I could
use that money for a new yeah I'm fine
Jesus like you think about it you think
about that is that if about exactly 52
days of mourning third day probably
probably like shopping online yeah I
wanted a new phone and share with you
you're adding the car you're not
checking out yet that's almost gone sir
yeah your wish list yeah so Richard was
charged with tampering with or
fabricating physical evidence providing
a false statement and murder his bond
was set for 1 million dollars which he
posted oh [ __ ] and so he he just
expected to appear in court soon so and
he also admitted to having an
extramarital affair that resulted in
pregnancy
but he was vague about whether the fact
of wife knew about it or not this guy
crazy any his money so he planned
together here's some bread then if you
could lay down a 1 million dollar no
it's like what are you do today
yeah it's 10 percent or something go
right he pretty gets the house or
something yeah
that's a [ __ ] time I love sitting at the
bank you mean like hi how are you
anybody wearing dress pants and [ __ ] I'm
like okay so I need to put a lien
against my house because I got a murder
trial no to me how would that
conversation like try to post bail yeah
oh oh wow he's got the bug I whoa he
looks [ __ ] nuts
he looks like he kill he's got [ __ ]
wall eyes dude you can't get away from
him tomorrow and he's had some
underneath the eyes he was insane any
the wool son Danny was like haunted
mansion eyes yeah her she does too she's
a victim
oh she's a victim really looks like now
I was nuts how did he turn into Isis
right like what the [ __ ] go back I did
the same he's like a white guy and then
now he's the ISIS guy at all sounds like
what if here does he was I to scratch
all along Oh was this lawyer laughing I
wasn't so happy
yeah his lawyer had a weird I go back to
the official enough but never yell
someone that's like he was like
mid-sentence it looks like an old man
he's like we just launched into the war
like that kind of [ __ ] you know we go
back to the Saturday she look how
beautiful house their yard
oh my god my dogs would love that that
looks like they were not like the lake
in the backers yeah you know a house is
nice when it doesn't have fences
yeah there we read faces that's dope
mm-hmm because my dogs would tell me
that was the only evidence of dog
here what do you this one dog one dog
she likes to travel you think look at
looking guys we got beautiful yard and
they're like did you [ __ ] yeah
she's a wanderer that [ __ ]
the see that's the thing is like they
only use the Fitbit to convict this guy
because it said a twelve hundred steps
instead of 125 steps you know well I
mean they use more than that the fact
that the timeline was wrong the IP
address Facebook post the alarm going
off everything used but I mean the
media's you know the patient like too
quickly the Facebook post was from his
computer her home okay hold IP address
yes
so with the alarm going off it's kind of
like how did you know nothing was
happening there buddy I better lower the
dog self-esteem to like dude I tracked
them to him and you're going to use the
tip it over my testimony and the dogs
actually an officer to also legitimate
officer like [ __ ] what I've been working
for I don't mean to be like this but I
do think it's very funny that like we
give dogs like awards when they do
things because they're cops dogs or
whatever and I think it's hilarious that
the idea that the dog is sitting there
while it gets an award and it's thinking
like I'm getting an award but there's no
[ __ ] there's no windows in it just
sitting there like it's just a day I've
got to eat I got a [ __ ] I want to walk I
want to drink I want to hang out I want
to play I want to get that bug yeah
that's it and it's a pain there's
nothing what is it and time yeah I want
to smell a thing so I get a treat yeah
it's just you know talking but not the
Duggan's that they're swelling with
pride like as it gets us cluttered but
it'll heal okay yeah the dog gets a
[ __ ] bag the reason the dog's eyes
when they start to water they said to
what you wanted I went to put the magic
touch build it up oh you're woke up in
the morning in to clean a bunch of
sherry your dog's eyes because there's
dogs always doing that [ __ ] those are
[ __ ] gross and they leak all kind of
[ __ ] their body does agree
right there crying see what do we see
what Pixar did does to people yeah look
at this [ __ ] hey there's nothing wrong
Pixar they make great movies it's not
about Pixar it's about what it does to
you you know Stan makes you it makes you
Tiffany can do I clearly need to perform
facades every cuz you know what I know
that I'm being frauded by my dog like oh
you're acting [ __ ] cute because
you're trying to manipulate me and
control me like a dog okay damn I don't
care how shaking I'll [ __ ] take it
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding News and if you guys
want to share a story there's a link
down in the description box below where
you can submit your story if you guys
want to watch more episodes click right
up here
[Music]